in a game scene you will have multiple
rooms you'll have caves you'll have
courtyards you'll have all sorts of
complex geometry and then people love to
blow up roofs and poke holes into
geometry all over the place and within
that now sound is streaming all around
the space and it's making its way around
geometry and the question becomes how do
you compute even the direct sound even
the initial sounds loudness interaction
which are important how do you find this
quickly because you're on the clock and
you have like 60 hundred sources moving
around and you have to compute all of
that very quickly you're listening to
the Microsoft Research podcast a show
that brings you closer to the cutting
edge of technology research and the
scientists behind it
I'm your host Gretchen heusinger if
you've ever played video games you know
that for the most part they look a lot
better than they sound that's largely
due to the fact that audible sound waves
are much longer and a lot more crafty
than visual light waves and therefore
much more difficult to replicate in
simulated environments but dr. nikunj
Raghavan Qi a senior researcher in the
interactive media group of Microsoft
Research is working to change that by
bringing the quality of game audio up to
speed with the quality of game video he
wants you to hear how sound really
travels in rooms around corners behind
walls outdoors and he's using
computational physics to do it today
dr. Raghavan she talks about the unique
challenges of simulating realistic sound
on a budget both money and CPU
explains how classic ideas in concert
hall acoustics need a fresh take for
complex games like Gears of War reveals
the computational secret sauce you need
to deliver the right sound at the right
time and tells us about Project triton
an acoustic system that models how real
sound waves behave in 3d game
environments to make us believe with our
ears as well as our eyes that and much
more on this episode of the Microsoft
Research podcast
[Music]
nikunj Raghavan G welcome to the podcast
I'm glad to be here you are a senior
researcher in MSRs Interactive Media
Group and you situate your research at
the intersection of computational
acoustics and graphics specifically you
call it fast computational physics for
interactive audio-visual applications
yep that's a mouthful right unpack that
how would you describe what you do and
why you do what gets you up in the
morning yeah so my passion is physics I
really like the mixture of computers and
physics so the way I got into this was
many many years ago I picked up this
book on C++ and it was describing
graphics and stuff and I didn't
understand half of it and there was a
color plate in there it took me two days
to realize that those were not
photographs they were generated by a
machine and I was like somebody took a
photo of a world that doesn't exist so
that is what excites me I was like this
is amazing this is as close to magic as
you can get and then the idea was I used
to build these little simulations and I
was like the exciting thing is you just
code up these laws of physics into a
machine and you see all this behavior
emerge out of it and you didn't tell the
world to do this or that it's just basic
Newtonian physics so that is
computational physics and when you try
to do this for games the challenge is
you have to be super fast you have one
sixtieth of a second to render the next
frame to produce the next buffer of
audio right so that's the fast portion
how do you take all these laws and
compute their results fast enough that
it can happen at one sixtieth of a
second repeatedly so that's where the
computer science enters the physics part
of it
so that's the sort of mixture of things
where I like to work in you've said that
light and sound or video and audio work
together to make gaming augmented
reality virtual reality believable why
are the visual components so much more
advanced than the audio is it because
audio is the poor relation in this
equation or is it just that much harder
to do
it is kind of both humans are visual
dominant creatures right because visuals
are what is on a conscious mind and when
you describe the world a language is so
visual right even for sound sometimes we
use visual metaphors to describe things
so that is part of it and part of it is
also that for sound the physics is in
many ways tougher because you have much
longer wavelengths and you need to model
wave diffraction wave scattering and all
these things to produce a believable
simulation and so that is the physical
aspect of it and also there's a
perceptual aspect our brain has evolved
in a world where both audio visual cues
exist and a brain is very clever it goes
for the physical aspects of both that
gave us separate information unique
information so visuals give you line of
sight high resolution right but audio is
lower resolution directionally but it
goes around corners it goes around rooms
that's why if you put on your headphones
and just listen to music at a loud
volume you're a danger to everybody on
the street right so audio is the
awareness part of it that is fascinating
because you're right what you can see is
what is in front of you but you could
hear things that aren't in front of you
if you can't see behind you but you can
hear behind absolutely you can hear
behind yourself and you can hear around
stuff around corners you can hear stuff
you don't see and that's important for
anticipating stuff already people coming
towards here and things like that so
there's all kinds of people here that
are working on 3d sound and head related
transfer functions and all the wave ants
group yes yeah how is your work
interacting with that so that work is
about if I tell you the spatial sound
field around your head how does it
translate into a personal experience in
your two ears so the h @ EF modeling is
about that aspect my work with John
Snyder is about how does the sound
propagate in the world right so if
there's a sound down a hallway what
happens during the time it gets from
there up to your head that's a work I
want you to give us a snapshot of the
current state of the art in
computational acoustics and there's
apparently two main approaches in the
field what
they and what's the case for each and
where do you live in this sector so
there's a lot of work in room acoustics
where people are thinking about okay
what makes a concert hall sound great
can we simulate a concert hall before
you build it so we know how it's gonna
sound and based on the constraints on
those areas people have used a lot of
ray tracing approaches which borrow on a
lot of literature and graphics and for
graphics ray tracing is the main
technique and it works really well
because the idea is you're using a short
wavelength approximation so light
wavelengths are submicron and if they
hit something they get blocked but the
analogy I like to use as sound is very
different the wavelengths are much
bigger so you can hold your thumb out in
front of you and blot out the Sun but
you've gonna have a hard time blocking
out the sound of thunder with a thumb
held out in front of you because the
waves will just wrap around and that's
what motivates our approach which is to
actually go back to the physical laws
and say instead of doing the short
wavelength approximation for sound we
revisit and say maybe sound needs the
more fundamental wave equation to be
solved to actually model these
diffraction effects for us the usual
thinking is that in games you're
thinking about we want a certain set of
perceptual cues we want walls to occlude
sound we want a small room to
reverberate less we want a large all to
reverberate more and the thought is why
are we solving this expensive partial
differential equation again can't we
just find some shortcut to jump straight
to the answer instead of going through
this long-winded route of physics and
our answer has been that you really have
to do all the hard work because there's
a ton of information that's folded in
and what seems easy to us as humans
isn't quite so easy for a computer and
there's no neat trick to get you
straight to the perceptual answer you
care about
much of the work in audio and acoustic
research is focused on indoor sound
where the sound sources within the line
of sight and the audience and the
listener can see what they were
listening to mm-hmm and you mentioned
that the concert hall has a rich
literature in this field
so what's the gap in the literature when
we move from the concert hall to the
computer specifically in virtual
environments yeah so games and virtual
reality the key demand they have is the
scene is not one room and with time it
has become much more difficult so a
concert hall is terrible if you can't
see the people who are playing the sound
right so it allows for a certain set of
assumptions that work extremely nicely
the direct sound which is the initial
sound which is perceptually very
critical just goes in a straight line
from source to listener you know the
distance so you can just use a simple
formula and you'd know exactly how loud
the initial sound is at the person but
in a game scene you will have multiple
rooms you'll have caves you'll have
courtyards you'll have all sorts of
complex geometry and then people love to
blow up roofs and poke holes into
geometry all over the place and within
that now sound is streaming all around
the space and it's making its way around
geometry and the question becomes how do
you compute even the direct sound even
the initial sounds loudness interaction
which are important how do you find
those quickly because you're on the
clock and you have like 60 hundred
sources moving around and you have to
compute all of that very quickly so
that's the challenge all right so let's
talk about how you're addressing it a
recent paper that you've published made
some waves sound waves probably no pun
intended
it's called parametric directional
coding for precomputed sound propagation
another mouthful but it's a great paper
and the technology is so cool talk about
this yeah yeah research that you're
doing so our main idea is actually to
look at the literature and lighting
again and see the kind of paths they'd
followed to kind of deal with this
computational challenge of how you do
these extensive simulations and still
hit that
engine CPU budget real-time and one of
the key ideas you pre-compute knew you
cheat you just look at the scene and
just compute everything you need to
compute beforehand right instead of
trying to do it on the fly during the
game so it doesn't reduce the limitation
that the scene has to be static but then
you can do these very nice physical
computations and you can ensure that the
whole thing is robust it is accurate it
doesn't suffer from all the sort of
corner cases that approximations tend to
suffer from and you have your result you
basically have a giant lookup table if
somebody tells you that the source is
over there and the listener is over here
tell me what the loudness of the sound
would be we just say okay we have the
giant table we will just go look it up
for you and that is the main way we
bring the CPU usage into control but it
generates a knockoff challenge that now
we have this huge table this is huge
amount of data that we've stored and
it's six dimensional the source can move
in three dimension and the listener can
move in three dimensions so we have this
giant table which is terabytes or even
more from data and the game's typical
budget is like hundred megabytes so the
key challenge we're facing is how do we
fit everything in that how do we take
this data and extract out something
salient that people listen to and use
that so you start with full computation
you start as close to nature as possible
and then you're saying okay now what
would a person hear out of this right
now let's do that activity of
instead of doing a shortcut now let's
think about okay a person here's the
direction a sound comes from if there's
a doorway the sound should come from the
doorway so we pick out these perceptual
parameters that are salient for human
perception and then we store those
that's the crucial way you kind of bring
down this enormous data set into a sort
of memory budget that's feasible so
that's the paper and how has it played
out in practice or in project as it were
so a little bit of history on this is we
had a paper in SIGGRAPH 2010 me and John
Schneider and some academic
collaborators and at that point we were
trying to think of just physical
accuracy so we took the
physical data and we were trying to stay
as close to physical reality as possible
and we were rendering that and around
2012 we got to talking with Gears of War
and the studio and we were going through
what the budgets will be how things
would be any of you need this needs -
this is gigabytes it needs to go to
megabytes really very quickly and that's
when we were like okay let's simplify
like what's the four most basic things
that you really want from an acoustic
system like wall should occlude sound
and things like that so we kind of
rewind it and came to it from this
perceptual viewpoint that I was just
describing
let's keep only what's necessary and
that's how we were able to ship this in
2016 and Gears of War 4 by just
rewinding and doing this process how is
that playing and you know project Triton
is the big project that we're talking
about how would you describe what that's
about and where it's going is everything
you've just described or is there yeah
aspects to it
project Triton is this idea that you
should recompute the wave physics
instead of starting with approximations
approximately later that's one idea
project Triton and the second is if you
want to make it feasible for real games
and real virtual reality and augmented
reality switch to perceptual parameters
extract that out of this physical
simulation and then you have something
feasible and the path we're on now which
brings me back to the recent paper you
mentioned right is in Gears of War we
shipped some set of parameters we were
like these make a big difference but one
thing we lagged was if the sound is say
in a different room and you're separated
by a doorway you would hear the right
loudness of the sound but its direction
would be wrong its direction would be
straight through the wall going from
source to listener and that's an
important spatial cue it helps you
orient yourself when sounds funnel
through doorways right and it's a cue
that sound designers really look for and
try to hand tune to get good ambience is
going so in the recent 2018 people
that's what we fixed we call this
portaling some made-up wood for this
effect of sounds going around doorways
but that's what we're modeling now
is this new stuff I mean people have
tackled these problems for a long time
yeah are you people the first ones to
come up with this portaling and i mean
the basic ideas have been around people
know that perceptually this is important
and there are approaches to try to
tackle this but i'd say because we're
using wave physics this problem becomes
much easier because you just have the
wave diffract around the edge with ray
tracing you face the difficult problem
that you have to trace out the rays
quote-unquote intelligently somehow to
hit an edge which is like hitting a
bull's-eye right right so the ray can
wrap around the edge so it becomes
really difficult most practical ray
tracing systems
don't try to deal with this edge
diffraction effect because of that
although there are academic approaches
to it in practice it becomes difficult
but as I've worked on this over the
years I've kind of realized these are
the real advantages of this
disadvantages are pretty clear it's slow
right so you have to pre-compute
but we're realizing over time that going
to physics has these advantages but the
pre-compute part is innovative in terms
of a thought process on how you would
accomplish the speed up I would say
they've been papers on precomputed
acoustics academically before but this
realization that mixing pre-computation
and extracting these perceptual
parameters that is a recipe that makes a
lot of practical sense because a third
thing that I haven't mentioned yet is
going to the perceptual domain now the
sound designer can make sense of the
numbers coming out of this whole system
because it's loudness it's reverberation
time how long the sound is reverberating
and these numbers that are super
intuitive sound designers they already
deal with them so now what you're
telling them is here you used to start
with a blank world which had nothing
right like the world before the act of
creation there's nothing it's just empty
space and you're trying to make things
reverberate this fear that now you don't
need to do that now physics will execute
first on the actual scene with the
actual materials and then you can say I
don't like what physics did here or
there let me tweak it let me modify what
the real
piss and make it meet the artistic goals
I have for my game
[Music]
we've talked about indoor audio modeling
but let's talk about the outdoors me for
now and the computational challenges to
making natural outdoor sounds sound
convincing yeah how have people hacked
it in the past and how does your work in
ambient sound propagation move us
forward here yeah we've hacked it in the
past okay this is something we realized
on Gears of War because the parameters
we use were borrowed again from the
concert hall literature and because
their parameters informed by concert
halls things sound like halls and rooms
back in the days of doom this tech would
have been great because it was all in
doors and rooms but in Gears of War we
have these open spaces and it doesn't
sound quite right outdoor sounds like a
huge hall and you know how do we do wind
ambiences and rain that's outdoors and
so we came up with a solution for them
at that time which we call out earnest
it's again an invented word or less
outdoor Innes I'm gonna use that because
the idea is trying to convey is it's not
a binary indoor/outdoor when you're
crossing a doorway or a threshold you
expect this smooth transition you expect
that I'm not hearing rain inside I'm
feeling nice and dry and comfortable and
now I'm walking into the rain and you
want the smooth transition on it so if
we built it sort of custom tech to do
that outdoor transition but at God is
thinking about what's the right way to
do this how do you produce the right
spatial impression of there's rain
outside it's coming through a doorway
the doorway is to my left and as you
walk it spreads all around you you're
standing in the middle of rain now and
it's all around you so we wanted to
create that experience so the ambient
sound propagation work was an intern
project and now we finish it up with
that collaborators and Cornell and that
was about how do you model extended
sound sources so again going back to
concert halls usually people have dealt
with point-like sources which might have
a directivity pattern but rain is like a
million little drops if you try to model
each and every drop that's not gonna get
you anywhere
so that's what the paper is about how to
treat it as one aggregate that somebody
gave us and we produce an aggregate sort
of energy distribution of that thing
along with its directional
characteristics and just encode that and
just encode it just encode it
how's it working it looks nice
it sounds good to my ears it sounds
great well you know and you're the picky
one I would imagine yeah I'm the picky
one and also when you're doing
iterations for paper you completely lose
objectivity at some point so well
reviewers give good feedback so yeah
okay well kind of riffing on that
there's another project going on that
I'd love for you to talk as much as you
can about called project acoustics and
kind of the future oh yeah that's where
we're going with this talk about that
that's really exciting so up to now
project Triton was an internal Tech
which we managed to propagate from
research into actual Microsoft products
internally project acoustics is being
led by Newell Cross's team in Azure
cognition and what they're doing is
turning it into a product that's
externally usable so trying to
democratize this technology so it can be
used by any game audio team anywhere
backed by as your compute to do the pre
computation which is key the azure
compute yeah because you know it took us
a long time with Gears of War to figure
out okay where's all this pre compute
going to happen right we had to figure
out a whole cluster story for themselves
how to get the machines how to procure
them and there's a big headache of
arranging compute for yourself and so
that's a logistically a key problem that
people face when they try to think of
pre computed acoustics the runtime side
project acoustics we're going to have
plug-ins for all the standard game audio
engines and everything so that makes
things simpler on that side but a key
blocker in my view was always this
question of where you going to
pre-compute
so now the answer is simple do you get
your as your batch account and you just
send your stuff up there and it just
computes send it to the cloud and the
cloud will rain it back down on you yes
it will send on beta a who's your
audience for project acoustics project
acoustics the audience
the whole game audio industry and our
real hope is that we see some uptake on
it when we announce it at GDC in March
and we want people to use it as many
teams small big medium everybody to
start using this because we feel there's
a positive feedback loop that can be set
up where you have these new tools
available designers realize that they
have these new tools available that have
shipped in triple-a games so they do
work and for them to give us feedback if
they use these tools we hope that they
can produce new audio experiences that
are distinctly different so that then
they can say to their tech director or
somebody for the next game we need more
CPU budget because we've shown you value
so a big exercise was how to fit this
within current budgets so people can
produce these examples of novel possible
experiences so they can argue for more
so to increase the budget for audio and
kind of bring it on par with graphics
over time as you alluded to earlier you
know if we get nothing across in this
podcast it's like people pay attention
to good audio give it its props because
it needs it let's talk briefly about
some of the other applications for
computational acoustics where else might
it be awesome to have a layer of realism
with audio computing one of the
applications that I find very exciting
is for audio rendering for people who
are blind I had the opportunity to
actually show the demo of her latest
system to Daniel Kish who if you don't
know he's the human echolocator and he
uses clicks from his mouth to actually
locate geometry around him and he's
always oriented he's an amazing person
so that was a collaboration actually we
had with the team in the garage they
released a game called ear hockey and it
was a nice collaboration like there was
a good exchange of ideas over there
that's nice because I feel that's a
whole different application where it can
have a potential social positive impact
the other one that's very interesting to
me is that we lived in 2d desktop
screens for a while
and now computing is moving into the
physical world that's the sort of
exciting thing about mixed reality is
moving compute out into this world and
then the acoustics of the real world
being folded into the sounds of virtual
objects becomes extremely important if
something were chool is right behind the
wall from you you don't want to listen
to it with full loudness that would
completely break the realism of
something being situated in the real
world so from that viewpoint good light
transport and good sound propagation and
both required things for the future
compute platform in the physical world
so that's a very exciting future
direction to me
[Music]
it's about this time in the podcast I
ask all my guests the infamous what
keeps you up at night question and when
you and I talked before we went down
kind of two tracks here and I felt like
we could do a whole podcast on it but
sadly we can't but let's talk about what
keeps you up at night
ironically to tee it up here it deals
with both getting people to use your
technology mm-hmm and keeping people
from using technology I'd say like five
years ago what used to keep me up at
night is like how are we gonna ship this
thing in Gears of War now what's keeping
me up at night is how do we make project
acoustics succeed and how do we you know
expand the adoption of it and in a small
way try to move the game audio industry
forward a bit and help artists do the
artistic expression they need to do in
games so that's what I'm thinking right
now how can we move things forward in
that direction I frankly look at video
games as an art form and I've gained a
lot in my time to be honest all of it
wasn't hard I was enjoying myself a lot
and I wasted some time playing games but
we all have our ways to unwind and waste
time but good games can be amazing they
can be much better than a Hollywood
movie in terms of what you leave them
with and I just want to contribute in my
small way to that giving artists the
tools to maybe make the next great story
you know all right so let's do talk a
little bit though about this idea of you
make a really good game mm-hmm
suddenly you've got a lot of people
spending a lot of time I won't say
wasting but we have to address the
nature of gaming and the fact that there
are you know you're upstream of it
you're an artist you're and the
technologist you're a scientist and it's
like I just want to make this cool stuff
downstream it's people want people to
use it a lot so how do you think about
that and the responsibilities of a
researcher in this arena you know this
reminds me of God wanting its book
cradle he kind of makes what there's a
scientist who makes ice 9 and it freezes
the whole planet so you see things about
video games in the news and stuff but I
frankly feel that the kind of games I've
participated in making these games are
very social experiences people meet on
the games a lot like sea of thieves is
all about you get a bunch of friends
together you're sitting on the couch
together and you're just going crazy
like on these pirate ships and trying to
just have fun so they're not the sort of
games where a person is being separated
from society by the act of gaming and
just is immersed in screen and it's just
not participating in the world there's
the kind of the opposite so games have
all these aspects and so I personally
feel pretty good about the games I've
contributed to I can if you see that so
I like to hear personal stories of other
researchers that come on the podcast so
tell us a little bit about yourself when
did you know you wanted to do science
for a living and how did you go about
making that happen
science for a living I was the guy in
sixth grade who would get up and say I
want to be a scientist so that was then
but what got me really hooked was
graphics initially like I told you I
found the book which had these color
plates and like wow that's awesome so I
was at UNC Chapel Hill graphics group
and I studied graphics for my graduate
studies and then in my second or third
year my advisor Ming Lin
she does a lot of research in physical
simulations how do we make water look
nice in physical simulations lots of it
is CGI how do you model that how do you
model plot how do you model hair so
there's all these physics for that and
so I took a course with her and I was
like you know what I want to do audio
because you get a different sense right
it's simulation not for visuals but you
get to hear stuff and like okay this is
cool this is different so I did a
project with her and I published a paper
on sound synthesis so like how rigid
bodies like objects rolling and bouncing
around and sliding make sound just from
physical equations and I found a cool
technique and I was like okay let me do
acoustics with this it's gonna be fun
and I'm gonna publish another paper in
year
and Here I am still trying to crack that
problem of how to do acoustics in spaces
yeah but what a place to be and speaking
of that you have a really interesting
story about how you ended up at
Microsoft Research and brought your
entire PhD codebase with you yeah it was
interesting time when I was graduating
MSR was my number one choice because I
was always thinking of this technology
as it would be creative games used this
one day this is the sort of thing that
would have a good application in games
and then around that time I got hired to
MSR and it was a multi core incubation
back then my group was looking at how do
these multi-core systems enable all
sorts of cool new things and one of the
things my hiring manager was looking at
was how can we do physically based on
synthesis and propagation so that's what
my PhD was so they license the whole
codebase and I built on that you don't
see that very often yeah it was nice
that's awesome
well nikunj as we close I always like to
ask guests to give some words of wisdom
or advice or encouragement however it
looks to you what would you say to the
next generation of researchers who might
want to make sound sound better yeah
it's an exciting area it's super
exciting right now because even like
just to start from more technical stuff
there's so many problems to solve with
acoustic propagation I'd say we've taken
just the first step of feasibility maybe
a second one the project acoustics but
we right at the beginning of this and
we're thinking there's so many missing
things like outdoors is one thing that
we've kind of fixed up a bit but we're
going to it's what sort of effects can
you model in the future like directional
sources as one we're looking at but
there's so many problems I kind of think
of it as the 1980s of graphics when
people first figured out that you can
make this work you can make light
propagation work what are the things
that you need to do to make it ever
closer to reality
we're still added so I think we're at
that phase with acoustics we've just
figured out this is one way that you can
actually ship in practical applications
and we know there are deficiencies in
its realism in many many places so I
think of it as a very rich area that
students can jump in and start
contributing nowhere to go but up yes
absolutely
nikunj Raghavan Qi thank you for coming
in and talking to us today thanks for
having me to learn more about dr.
Niccole track of on Qi and the science
of sound simulation visit
microsoft.com/testlabguides
[Music]